in our study of world history we have
looked at many different empires and
several of them are depicted on this map
right over here we spent a lot of time
on the Roman Empire and the highlighted
yellow you see the Roman Empire at
roughly its maximum extent and on this
timeline you see the Roman kingdom and
then the Roman Republic and then the
Roman Empire which ends in the fifth
century although the eastern Roman
Empire the Byzantine Empire continues on
for roughly another thousand years now
we also have depicted here a significant
Persian Empire you have the Parthian
Empire and they were preceded by the
Seleucid Empire and they were succeeded
by the sustaining Empire but I have the
Parthians depicted here on the timeline
and on the map I also show Han China
both the eastern and western han
dynasties you can see on this timeline
as well and in India I show the Maurya
dynasty on the timeline I don't depict
it here on the map
but on the map I show the cushion Empire
and I also show it on the timeline now
the reason why I wanted to pick these
empires at this specific time in the
world is to highlight the fact that they
weren't operating in complete isolation
in fact as we get to the second and
first century BCE especially as we get
into the Common Era we start seeing a
significant amount of Trade and
interaction between these empires not to
say that there wasn't trade and
interaction before that time but it
started to get accelerated and to a
large degree
it got accelerated because you had these
contiguous empires that at least within
their borders were able to provide some
level of stability for someone to travel
across roads or travel across borders
and so you start to see the emergence of
these trading networks in red you see
trading roads or paths in red and in
blue you see those paths by sea and this
isn't even comprehensive and even what I
show on the empires or many other
smaller kingdoms that also existed in
the world that I just don't have
depicted here but what this contiguous
block of empires allowed is for the
trade of goods and ideas and some
collectively the routes that were used
for this trade is referred to as the
Silk Road or the Silk Roads or really
you could say the silk routes and so
it's a collective number of paths that
people use to trade things now why call
it silk what all boils down to silk
being a major commodity of trade at this
time period so if you want to think
about the different things that were
traded around the world this is just a
sample of it silk which comes from
cocoons of these silk worms that eat
mulberry leaves was considered a sign of
wealth it was considered the finest
cloth and China had a monopoly on how to
make silk for many hundreds of years
even after the period that we were
talking about right here so you can
imagine around the world people were
interested in getting access to that
Chinese silk but silk wasn't the only
thing that was being traded in fact in
order to trade you need to give
something in exchange for even that silk
one of the Chinese motivations for
creating with others is having access to
horses horses were valuable not just for
transporting goods but also in war
especially fighting some of their
northern enemies who had access to
horses they also were able to get gold
from Europe be able to get cotton from
India in Europe you also had other
manufactured goods so you had this
fairly vast trading enterprise emerge
between these different parts of the
world and to be clear some of the things
that were traded allowed or facilitated
the trade itself
I mentioned horses were source of
transportation but camels in particular
were very powerful sources of
transportation especially across Central
Asia and as you get into the Middle East
and Africa because you have these large
swaths of desert camels could not only
carry a lot but they had a lot of
stamina and they did not have to stop
for water as frequently a lot of world
history we focus on the large non
nomadic empires like the Roman Empire
and Han China but as trade became more
important especially as you go through
Malaysia you could imagine that many of
the people who were very good at trading
who are good at moving things were
people who are good at moving themselves
in particular the nomadic people in
Central Asia many of their cities along
these trade routes became more and more
wealthy and more and more powerful now
as I mentioned goods were not the only
thing that were transported along these
routes one of the not-so-good things was
the spread of disease so in the
historical record
we have two major plagues in Rome during
the Roman Empire and we believe these
plagues were smallpox although some
people believe it might have been gzhel
and it is believed that it came from
traders and it came from Asia from the
Middle East and these were significant
plagues and the reason why we think that
it was due to trade is that there's some
evidence in Han China during this first
plague of similar symptoms of a similar
plague but it really affected Rome in
these plagues it's estimated that as
much as 10% of the population might have
died in certain cities it might have
been 25 30 percent of the population
some historians even point to these
plagues as destabilizing the Roman
Empire and this is a theme that you'll
see often in world history where if you
have a population that doesn't have
exposure to something say smallpox and
all of a sudden they encounter a
population that does have exposure well
that smallpox might wreak had it but it
wasn't just disease you also have the
spread of ideas and technology and
religion and the two religions that
perhaps benefited the most from the
early trade along the Silk Route or the
Silk Roads or Christianity and Buddhism
and Buddhism in particular was very
appealing to many of these Silk Road
merchants the cushion Empire in
particular started to significantly
spread Buddhism in previous videos we
talked about Ashoka sending missionaries
but the cushion Empire helped spread
Buddhism into China and into the Far
East so what we talked about in this
video is the very beginning of the Silk
Road as we
get into the first few centuries BCE or
the first few centuries of the Common
Era but as we'll see the Silk Road will
continue on for many hundreds or really
over a thousand years